hello and welcome to a special segment
of GameSpot's play for all I'm excited
for this one because we're talking about
two games that have been tremendously
influential on me so here I am doing
everything I can to talk about Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater 1 & 2 remastered with
simonetta Chur chief operating officer
from Vicarious Visions
and Shane O'Neill a professional skater
how you guys doing good here I have
plenty to talk about whether it's the
game or skate culture in general but
I'll kind of hit it off with some of
some of the groundwork for the game
itself so imma throw it over to you
Simon can you tell me about kind of when
you're remastering thps1 and to how much
of the base game are you using I know
people have been seeing gameplay of it
but in terms of Vicarious Visions
developing the game like how do you
balance mechanics that you've seen
throughout the series and then some of
the some of the the basics that we know
from 1 & 2 so yeah I mean initially we
set out to create a faithful remaster of
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 1 & 2 you know I
mean we've got all 19 of the original
levels we've got all the original pros
but we also have added a bunch of new
pros including Shane who I'd like to
welcome to the franchise along with the
other cast of new pros that we have in
the game because you know as
skateboarding has evolved over time it's
gotten more diverse and we really wanted
to reflect that with the with the pros
that we had in the game and so well
while we set out to do a faithful
remaster we knew that there were some
things like that that we wanted to
change we we also included a robust
create a park feature that you know will
allow players to create their their own
skate parks with with really great
robust tools that'll allow them to to to
do things that they've never been able
to do before along those lines and and
share those parks with their friends
online in terms of the what we took from
the originals the the Geo and everything
we ported all of the
original geometry from the original
games for those 19 levels and so for the
nostalgic fan and people like yourself
Michael who are you know remembering
that how Tony Hawk's Pro skaters went
into the original games felt I think are
going to be you know pleasantly
surprised and satisfied with how this
game feels because the the geometry is
the same even though we've put you know
all new artwork on it and you know it
have it you know uh presdent 4k all
those things are gonna you know add to
this sort of like meshing of the old and
new in a way that I think people are
gonna be super stoked about I'm
personally excited about it but I do
want to kind of ask about what it's like
to remake a game that had been like
captured such a specific culture back
then and trying to kind of recapture or
kind of capture a new audience in 2020
what what is that like uh yeah I mean we
we really want the game to be authentic
right you know we want it to be true to
the skate culture today I mean great and
you're still a skateboarding superhero
and in this game and you're doing tricks
and combos and you know things that that
are beyond what what most actual skaters
can do but that's the fantasy of being
the skateboarding superhero but beyond
that I mean we really wanted to bring
the the authenticity of the originals
you know the the music and and the
culture to to the fans and I think that
with with skateboarding meant to be in
the Olympics this year which I
unfortunately have been canceled you
know I think that that just speaks
volumes to the the longevity that the
sport has and how it was continuing to
to be a big part of sporting world
I'm Shane can you speak to what it's
like to kind of carry on I guess carry
on that torch of skate culture and going
into thps one and two and joining
these veterans that so many people know
and love yeah well I mean I played the
games you know growing up and loved the
games and it was a big part of what kept
me skateboarding originally because it
was an easy way to learn what the tricks
were to you know obviously as some
wishes saying like do things that are
just you know kind of not possible as
far as me being in the game like I'm
it's hard to explain how exciting that
is to be in that when I was asked to be
a knowledge you know was unbelievable to
be in a new game school to being a
remastered version of the arguably the
best skateboarding game to ever exist is
it's pretty you know huge on us go super
cool can you see I guess Simon can you
speak to the process of relicensing the
music or trying to get that music back
after so long yeah that the process of
licensing the the old tracks from the
previous games I mean as you can expect
in some cases it's difficult 20 years
have gone by and you can't necessarily
track down all of the license ores
sometimes they're potentially you know
disputes over maybe who owns the
copyright but so in general we we wanted
to get everything again we we weren't
able to get a couple of tracks but we
have the vast majority of the songs from
the original Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 1 &
2 games I'm super stoked about that I
mean we've got some of my favorites like
Goldfinger Rage Against the Machine
those songs are so iconic I mean you
still hear so many of the songs from
that soundtrack or from those tracks on
the radio or in television commercials
you know I mean it's just like they're
so everywhere and when you hear them for
for people like me I just instantly
think oh man I
that's Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 1 & 2 I
Cameron you know I used to skate to
those well I used to skate on my
controller to those you know and and
have a blast so yeah I think it's
awesome I think it'll be really cool and
it's
it's a lot different it's a just a
completely different era like back then
I didn't know the names of the songs and
I wasn't gonna go and buy a CD you know
and I'm 11 years old or something so I
think it's really cool that they are the
same songs and we have this access to to
really you know find that yeah it's
funny you mentioned that because on my
11th birthday I actually spent my
birthday money to buy to Bad Religion
CDs because better religion was in Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater - and totally totally
changed my life after that and also I
think Simon I want to ask about using
the likeness of the older versions of
these skaters so I mean Shane you're
gonna be looking young in this game
especially compared to everyone else so
I don't know if you can provide any
insight and select the decision behind
you know keeping their likenesses
current and also having Tony Hawk
wearing wearing pads and the other cover
you know it just seemed to make sense to
have them appear as they currently do
today especially because you know as we
were talking before about sponsorship
and everything a lot of the sponsors
have changed for the original skaters
over the years and so you know putting
them in what they are currently wearing
having them be the personas that they
are today what we felt like was
important and the right way to portray
them with regard to Tony and and pads
and a helmet I mean just in general
having that be one one of the care one
of the appearances of him in the game is
that mean that's how he really looks
when he's skating I mean you know when
when you when you see him on his vert
ramp at his house or at his office it's
like you know he's geared up and so we
wanted that to look authentic as well I
think one of the things I want to ask -
is about move sets and tricks that we'll
be able to do in the game are you
keeping all the tricks from one and two
contained in there or are you also
incorporating some of the new stuff some
of the more modern tricks so yes that we
we have the original tricks
from the from the original Tony Hawk pro
skater one in two games we we also we
added certain things from later in the
series because we wanted to we wanted to
make sure that for people who just think
about the Tony Hawk pro skater series in
general that they they got the
experience that they were expecting and
for example Reaver wasn't introduced
until Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 3 but you
really you really need revert in order
to have the the long combos and to play
the game the way that I think many
people when they think about Tony Hawk
pro skater they're like oh yeah that's
it's like he's an endless combos with
revert and manual and and all these
things and so just simply is more like a
quality of life improvement we wanted to
include things like revert and spine
transfer and acid drop in the game with
regard to other new tricks you know I
mean that we do have new pros in the
game who who we want to make sure that
they have special tricks that represent
their skate style and what they do and
so so you'll get to see that as well
so I would just like to add also I think
it's such a cool take on remastering a
game but also adding a few little things
like that the age thing and and also
just the reboots and then a few other
things that I think will help the game I
actually personally think that's super
cool so these are gonna be faithful
remakes of 1 & 2 but in this day and age
we also have games that are get ongoing
support and get new content added so how
do you plan to support the game after
launch if with anything else I mean we
will support the game launch to make
sure that you know if there are any
issues that need to be be addressed you
know further for the sake of of gameplay
and things like that we have that but
we're right now we're not talking about
any other post launch role can you give
me also before before we dip out of this
I know that multiplayer was actually a
big big part of
the experience and playing things like
like horse or well skate and then just
like trying to rack up the highest score
in two minutes with my friends after
school what can we expect out of
multiplayer modes and online support and
I'm super excited for for this I mean
that we still have two players
split-screen gameplay so for the people
who remember that and love just like
sitting on their sofa and playing with
their friends you totally get that
experience back again and and and we're
super excited for that but we are also
and you know bringing forward into the
game online multiplayer so you'll be
able to play with other people online in
games like trick attack score challenge
combo challenge combo Mombo the various
various games like that from the series
that people remember and and like I
mentioned at the beginning too
you'll be able to share your creative
parks online and you'll be able to skate
in those with your friends as well
that's good to hear so before we take
off I want to kind of throw it to Shane
and Simon is there anything else that
you want to add that we may have not
touched on that you do want to make sure
folks out there know for me I'm just
excited able to get to play it like
myself and it's going to be super cool
infer for me the you know the last thing
that I I want to say is again you know
welcome to Shane and the new pros who
are in the game I'm really excited for
for the the fans not just the old fans
but the new fans to get to to play and
experience those those new skaters and
you know beyond that
September 4th man that's when you can
get it if you if you preorder the game
you can get the the warehouse demo ahead
of time Shane and Simon thank you so
much for taking time out of your day to
talk about Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 1 & 2
remastered it's coming out real soon on
PC epic game store Xbox one and ps4 and
all of you fine folks out there thank
you so much for watch
and we'll see you around because we got
so much more content for GameSpot's play
for all thanks for having us thanks a
lot be safe Michael McShane
[Music]